tonight for the tampa bay rays that's
going to be right-handed drew rasmussen
i don't think that you can refer to him
as an opener anymore this will be his
fourth open slash start
ground ball right side rasmussen's gonna
have to get over there to cover and he
finds the bag in time
that walt did halfway between first and
second lucho got over there
to make the pick up and then rasmussen
had to hightail it to first
wider into center kiermeyer closing
makes the catch to retire the side
bottom of the first inning orioles
nothing race coming to bed against
left-hander john means randy three of
seven against means with a couple home
runs off him
and a chopper gonna be charged by mateo
and he cannot find the handle on it
mateo can
in on that
chopper
newly was gonna have to hurry and just
could not pull it off so a nine-game
hitting streak now for
brandy arun serena and here's nelson
cruz
one two
swing and a miss fastball on the outside
corner at 93.
and means strikes out cruz for the first
out
three and two two outs the pitch
fastball strike three actually a change
up on the inside corner
and a beautifully located pitch as mean
strikes out his second in a scoreless
first we go to the second 24 pitch first
inning john means
means one-two pitch and he got him yeah
target in and fastball runs away that's
how good of stuff and fastball he has
mike zanino right-handed hitter is means
deals 2-2
swing and a miss fastball 94 down the
middle no single no nothing four
strikeouts for means he's retired six in
a row cedric mullins will bat for the
second time
no score here in the top of the third
swing and a miss the ball popping loose
recovered by zanino throw down to luplow
will retire the side bottom three at the
truck no score
john means sharp so far the one-two
pitch
and there's another swing and a miss
he guessed it by him at 94 on the
outside black
that's five punch outs for means one
down in the bottom of the third
12th pitch of the at-bat coming up
and it was a lot of work but he got him
so three straight strikeouts for john
means six in the game two down
and here's randy rose arena randy a
little chopper of a base hit that's the
only hit of the game for the race so far
nancy liner up the left field side a
fair ball
and will bound out of play
for a ground rule double
so the battle between rosarina and means
and arose arena has his second hit of
the night and now a runner in scoring
position for nelson cruz
one-two pitch
got him this time
i almost got him last time no question
this time so means winds up striking out
the side well seven strikeouts now
change up freezes
nelson cruz here's wander franco we'll
leave things off
because there's a swing and a chopper
towards short mateo wakes back on it
tried to play it and he bobbles it'll be
an error on the tail as soon as i saw
him just kind of wait for the baseball
figure he's going to be in trouble and
sure enough he was it's an e6
and a shot into right that ball is going
to be over the head of santander
bronco's going to score easily it's
going to be a stand-up double and the
raids take a one-nothing lead
margot driving in his 49th run now you
take advantage of the air and then
margot gets a fastball that he can
handle
and able to just shoot it over the head
of santander
mikey homer in four consecutive games
longest streak of his career
center shoots one deep to left will it
have enough yes god
home run for mike zedino
gets his 26th home run of the year
he has a five-game home run streak
homer in five consecutive games
for mike zanina and now randy rosarina
who was already singled and doubled
against means
randy swinson grounds another one up the
middle base hitting the center field
kermit with a hard turn around second
stumbled a bit heads for third but
mullen stumbles two in center and
caremeyer makes it a third without a
throw runners at the corners and randy
is three for three another mashing of
the oriole pitching staff
nelson cruz
and now 1-1 there's a towering drive way
up into the air in the left heading back
as hayes to the warning track at the
wall gone
his first trip at canterfield homer as a
ray is a three-run shot to bust the game
open it's six-nothing rays
last couple of swings he looked like it
was just a tick off
well his timing was
much better right there and here's juan
de franco
and a face hit lined into right
santander
will cut it off
and franco is aboard so that's four
straight hits to open the raised half of
the fifth inning wanted to the count
here to allow
fine drive that's going to be out of the
reach of urias
here comes margot to score loud digs for
second and he's in there with a double
so the rays make it a seven nothing ball
game brandon lau picking up his 69th run
batted in
cenino pops it up on the infield maria's
at the bag and now back to the bag drops
it the run will score
and zenino is aboard the raids add
another run
on the error
charge to ureas but here is randy and
rosarenda three for three tonight
a little tapper that's going to be a
tough play
and the throw to first is going to go up
the right side down toward the bullpen
and rosarina is on base again that's
gonna be a base hit he is four for four
cruz's number of hits is a race 15 hits
his array and six of them are homers
[Applause]
of here
nelson cruz
put a charge into that one new second
home run of the night
that will make it
a ten nothing ball game
that ball's hit well
gap and right center look out
sliding catch by santander
and cedric mullen slides behind him to
avoid the collision and then right here
out of nowhere comes anthony santander
so we talked about the ankle feeling
better there's an example of it
two out of the ninth raisin out away
from their ninth team shutout
1-2
fly ball center field phillips is there
the rays win
ray's win this one it's a ten-nothing
final
the offense down the middle of this game
very impressive
you